[Music]
oh I can't feel my legs my arm is broken
I'm sorry
[Music]
hello Drew
how come
on
[Music]
foreign
Oh Daddy no no
did you hear something no I didn't hear
anything at all
[Music]
I'm Gail hail Halestorm author of the
book you're dead I'm rich
found is in shock after the unthinkable
has happened a brutal Killing Spree that
left one team dead that's it two teams
dead and this small town shaken and
stirred it's just like these police are
combing the area for Clues it seems
there are no Witnesses available at this
time there were no suspects in custody
police are asking anyone to come forward
report live for black TV white folks are
dead we're getting the out of here
let's go
hey
do you think the Press is going to want
to talk to us oh girl no the Press only
wants to interview the most ignorant
person they can find I'm on TV
first cops nowadays oh man be a star son
what can you tell us about Drew well she
had the fat ass son I mean it was like
bang how close were you to the victim
real close
to the movies wolf then she woke up
talking about pressing charges so I just
pulled my tongue out of ass and left
what would have been your last words to
Drew
run
tomorrow
oh I am scared oh
excuse me
I think I paid my money like everybody
else up in here
combined I know you better get out of my
face
out of my face out of my face
this is all me up in here you handle
that
this movie is good
hey baby
came back just in time
about to get it on with shakers fear
yeah I got you
I got you on camera you want candy
camera now
you ain't know that
hello hey girl I'm gonna move it uh I'll
shake a spin love
oh
you lions for Christ's sake will you
just shut your trash shut up hold on
you sit down
your ass is grass
[Applause]
please
Jackie Chan movies
and Big Mama's House
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right all right hold on a second yes
give me a moment
oh yeah
ah okay
[Music]
hello
foreign
[Music]
okay okay hi
think I know why you're mad Mr Cat
I didn't mean to go poopy in your litter
box
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you want to be to me
yeah
[Music]
come on
yeah yeah come on
oh
is that all you got come on give me your
best shot
[Music]
I'm telling you Professor it was
possessed Theo did you see this animal
no I didn't I heard all the commotion
but by the time I went in there I guess
it was gone
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right mother
hey Kate you hungry how about a little
snack of this
gotcha
[Music]
I know what you're thinking did I fire
three shots or 117 well
do you feel lucky
Punk
do you
feel lucky
do you feel lucky shoot me
okay fine making this move s bite
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Angel Style
whoa okay
come on
ah
a
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
you want to tell me what's really
bothering you
well
there's something I need to
I saw a tape
I think you should know about it
it had these really shocking images
saying Brenda
it was Mardi Gras I never drank vodka
before and I was out of beads no not
that tape Cindy well I guess it's just
an urban legend
you watch it
and as soon as it's over your phone
rings and a creepy voice says you're
gonna die in seven days
and seven days later
when did you watch it a week ago
a week ago tonight Brenda
[Music]
my God
oh my God you
we should have seen the look on your
face
you got me
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God
sister
oh that did not
I just let her look on your face when
you are scared girl you are too easy
I got you with the old fake hair
[Music]
well I know oh come on I was just
kidding well you've taken it too far
Brenda
foreign
[Music]
well it's it's way past your bedtime
when she wrapped me to sleep in your big
strong arms
plenty of room under the covers
it's a hot night
you don't need to wear pajamas
[Music]
where is my daughter are you mad I am
your daughter no you're not
oh
get to me
what did you do with Sue I didn't touch
her I swear I don't believe you please
become sex she's a girl
[Music]
foreign
what is that thing
don't know
maybe Sydney was right
[Music]
please sir all I need is five minutes
and I told you Campbell no more paranoid
on-air rants about the supernatural I
know this station is about sex violence
in the weather yes that reminds me we're
gonna need that porn star shot dead in a
hurricane story one hour
meanwhile a tornado in Charleston
threatens a clothing optional Beach
where just yesterday a naked couple was
brutally murdered this just five miles
the response
turning now to sports
and an evil videotape that kills anyone
who watches it in seven days it's true
we're all in danger there's an alien
force out there that's trying to prevent
you from knowing the truth it's a
horrible face can you hear me correction
there really is no danger actually I
didn't really mean anything I just said
yes I did every word
oh shizzle gizengarve it
one three four nineteen Gerson blocking
bracket four six nine I've been cleaning
after this dumbass cracker giggens for
10 years but I've been hitting it with
his woman for 12. know what I'm saying
she likes her some chocolate
Sharpton for president y'all I'm Audi
peace
oh
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
time to go back down the well
ah
thank you no don't hurt him
Cindy you have to come outside the
aliens aren't invading
don't worry Cody I'll save you wait
wait don't do this you don't have to be
evil
I know what happened to you
Tabitha
I know what your mom did that was wrong
you were just a little girl and you're
still that little girl just
a lot more corpseed with really bad
teeth but maybe all you need is
a mother
[Music]
and a father
foreign
[Music]
broken the curse and freed my soul I'll
never have to kill again
[Music]
I'm just screwing with you
I just want to tell you both good luck
we're all Canyon